Mark:  Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome back to The Rake Multiplayer!
Mark:  We got Bob-- *bursts into giggles*
Bob & Mark: *laughing hysterically*
Mark:  *through giggles* You guys don't know how funny that looked on my screen!
Bob & Wade: *laughing*
Bob:  Well I could see Wade, and I was like "Yes!  I have to--"
(all laughing)
Mark:  *dying of laughter*
Mark:  Wade you might be running into something over there.
Bob:  Wade, come here!
Bob:  Blaaaaargghh
Bob:  Come here!
Wade:  Where are ya, Bob?
Mark:  So, you guys wanted to see more because in the last episode
Mark:  we didn't FULLY take it seriously
Mark:  And obviously with the start of this episode, we're taking it MUCH more seriously
Mark:  Um, but we actually have an objective
Mark:  And we got Bob in!   So hi, Bob.
Bob:  Hi!
Mark:  Hello!
Mark:  How are you?
Bob & Wade: *making weird noises*
Mark:  So- so Bob
Mark:  Did you know there's a monster in these woods?
Bob:  Well I assume that's why I have the gun
Bob:  I'm either supposed to kill YOU or kill the monster-- I'm not...
Bob:  I'm not killing you, so...
Mark:  Well, if-- if we start to piss you off by the end of this round...you can--
Bob:  Can I actually kill you with this?
Mark:  I'm, uh-- (Wade: Shoot me!)
Mark:  Shoot Wade! (Wade: SHOOT ME)
Mark:  Wait, how do you know who's who??
Bob:  Yeah, actually...
Bob:  Well you're the one who's not going like this-- *laughing*
Mark:  NO IT ME
Mark:  IT WADE
Mark:  I AM WADE
Mark:  ME WADE *trails into giggles*
Bob:  *cracking up*
Wade:  You don't look anything like me!
Mark: ME WADE
Mark: YOU SHUT UP
Mark & Bob: *laughing*
Wade:  I WILL NOT
Mark:  YOU ASS BAG
Mark: FUCK YOUR FACE--
Wade: --YOU THINK I AM BUT ISN'T
Mark:  Oh YEAH, Rick??
Mark:  *laughing* Well fuck-- well
Mark:  IIIIIIIIIII'M OUTTA HERE
Bob: *losing it*
Wade:  You come right back here, I'm not done with you!
Mark: *laughs*
Wade: Oh, you're right there!
Bob: Oh fuck, I'm gonna fucking pass out
Mark & Wade: *laugh*
Bob: Also this one's Wade
Mark: Yeah--  *dissolves into laughter*
Wade: You were aiming, like, WAY over here on my screen
Bob: No-- well yeah, so when I'm-- I'm pointing right at your face right now
Bob:  But the gun on my screen is pointed like three feet to the right of you
Mark:  Oh yeah, wow. That's true.
Bob: But the aiming's right on your face right now
Mark: Oh, okay
Wade: *sarcastic* Good, I'm glad
Mark: Well, anyway let me go grab cameras 'cause we're gonna need them
Bob: How's it goin' Wade? (Wade: Bob there are more shells in here, by the way)
Wade: There's more shotgun shells in here
Bob:  Well, I picked up one of them, I guess I'm the only one with a shotgun
Bob: So I might as well have all of 'em
Mark: Yeah, there's a sniper rifle we're gonna get but--
Wade: I believe there's two of each gun somewhere on the map, I don't know where...
Mark:  Oh yeah!  There's a house that YOU went to, but we didn't go...
Mark: So let's-- let's go through the woods and make sure we go together
Mark: And remember where we're going
Bob: We went  this way
Mark: Yeah, so we-- you can run
Bob: All right!
Wade: So bear traps...
Bob: Hey, if uh... if the monster shows up
Bob: Uh, I think we should all react in the same way
Mark: Okay, all right
Mark: So you-- you guys wanna go
Mark: "WAAAHH" or-- or
Bob: I think our-- no, no, no
(Mark: Uh oh!)
Bob: Whoa, whoa, whoa oh shit!
(Mark: WHOA WHOA HEY)
Mark: *laughing*
(Wade: OH HEY *laughs*)
Mark: So uh--
Wade: Good thing you had that shotgun!
Mark: Well that was early!
(Bob: Ohhhh)
Mark: *laughs*
Bob: Uh...
Mark:  Yeah we're-- we gotta-- we gotta...
Bob: Wait, I was gonna say-- I was trying to say
Bob: I think our reaction should be this
Bob:  WAaaAHhhHH NO *screaming hysterically*
Mark: *laughing*
Wade: Yeah, well, if the Rake shows up... we should be sure to do that (Mark: Yeah)
Bob: Okay, Wade
(Mark: I'll- I'll be ready.  I'll be ready...)
Bob: I'll be ready, too
Mark: All right, there's--
(Wade: Sounds good, Bob!)
Mark: There's bear traps up here that we can get to, uh...
Mark:  ...trap him so that he doesn't do that
Bob: I fucking hear the monster again
Wade: Um--
Mark: Was it that-- was it that house, or was it--  oohhh
[Rake rustling] Mark: That's not good
Bob: He's clip-clopping around behind us
Mark: Was it this one?
(Wade: I'll get the ones that are up here)
Mark: Okay
(Bob: Oh god, what's that sound?)
Mark: I dunno
(Bob: What's that big gong sound?)
Mark: Okay...
(Bob: The gong sound sounds--)
Mark: You got it?
(Wade: Um... yeah)
Mark: All right, Bob-- eeuuh
Mark:  AHH!
[Rake screeching]
Mark: Ow...
(Wade: JESUS)
Wade: WhwHAOAA
Mark & Bob: *laughing*
Mark: Did you freak out like we planned?
Bob: Yeah, he did the freak out
Mark: All right, uh...
Mark: Okay, Wade, you have your bear traps right?
Wade: Yeah
(Mark: Okay, whoa! What is that?)
Mark: Oh, I found a piggy!  Well, finally!
Bob:  Should I kill it?
Mark:  Uuuhhh no
(Wade: No)
Mark:  All right, uh-
Wade:  Bob, where'd you go?
Bob:  I'm over here, I'm fine
(Mark: Wade, was this the one with the other ones?)
Wade: Yeah, Bob, get the bear traps from up here
Wade: Mark, go over to the left there
(Mark: Yeah)
Mark: Yeah, there's a tent over there
[Rake screeches]
(Bob: Oh shit!)
Bob: Christ! I hate you guys!
Mark & Wade: *laughing at the success of their douchery*
Bob: Damn it!
Bob: I'm-- daahh Jesus!
Mark:  All right,  where was-- where's--
Mark: *laughs*
Wade: There's some in here
Bob: You guys are just fucking with me!
Mark: *evil laugh* No, no!  Whoa...
Mark:  The music got-- the music seems way more intense than the last time that I played
Bob: Where are you guys?
Bob: No NO NO no fuck you!
Mark: Oh geez
Wade: We're right next to you
Mark: Oh my god
(Bob: Where?! Help me!)
Mark: Oohh god
(Wade: Where are you??)
Mark: That music, though... dat uh--
Wade: He went to the house, right to left of where we--
Mark: Oh, he-- he went there... yeah
Bob: I'm right here!
(Mark:   I don't think there were any more bear traps for him)
Wade: Okay, Bob, umm...
Wade: Or Mark, Bob, let's go this way
Mark: Okay
Wade:  I think the house, or the other house and the waterfall is this direction?
Mark: Uh huh
(Bob: You guys are just fucking with me)
Mark:  No, we're- we're actually not this time
Wade: I mean, we did that time, but...um...
Bob:  I thought it was like an alien... anal probe...
Bob:  like lifting... gravity... beam
Mark: I mean...uhhh... it could be?
Bob: It's whatever I want it to be, baby?
(Mark: Yeah pretty much)
Mark:  All right, so in here...
Mark:  euugh
(Bob: No NO no no)
[loud crunching noises]
(Mark: eeuaahh!)
Mark: WHY ARE THE SOUNDS LOUDER THAN THEY WERE BEFORE?
Wade: I don't know
Mark: They're SO much louder
Wade: Oh yeah this was the place with nothing
Mark:  eeuuhh... Oh yeah, this-- oh this wasn't the cave that's right...
Mark:  The cave is to the left of here
Mark:  The actual cave
(Wade: Yeah...)
Mark:  All right, so...
Bob:  Wait, where did... there's only two of us...
Mark:  Huh?
Bob:  Where'd the other person go?
(Mark: What??)
Wade:  He must've walked out already
Mark:  Oh, I-- I went out
Bob: Oh
(Mark: Yeah)
Mark:  And got eaten!  The Rake got me!
Mark:  NOOOOOOOOOOOOO
Bob:  *laughs*
(Wade: Ooohhh Jesus!)
Mark:  Oh-hoh-- all right, if we go left... left is the other cave
Mark:  I'm pretty sure...
Bob:  I'm still fairly certain you guys are just fucking with me
Mark:  No!  I mean, uh-- usually
Mark:  But not this one time
(Bob: Yeah)
Wade:  I'm stuck on a tree...
(Bob: That's, uh how this works)
Mark:  Yeah, I don't know what's going on with that... me also
Bob:  I think it's the server
Mark:  Yeah probably
(Mark's Character: *screaming*)
Mark:  WHY AM I FREAKING OUT??
Bob:  What??
(Mark: It happened again!  It did the thing!)
Mark:  Where my guy just freaks out for no goddamn reason
Bob:  I know!  I can hear you screaming
(Wade: Yeah)
Mark:  *laughing*  Just- my guy,
*high pitched* "WUUHH!! OOHHHhhHh!!!
Mark:  "whOAA GOD!!!"
Bob:  *laughs*  Your character just snapped under the pressure, Mark
Wade:  This is just a rock formation, but...
Bob:  I'm hearing lots of tree creakies
Mark:  Yeah...
Wade:  Oh, this is the place we were looking for
(Mark:  Ah!  Yeah, this is what we were looking for)
Mark:  Oh, there we are
Bob:  Oh, hey, loud...
Wade:  Bob, you have the shotgun, why don't YOU lead the way?
Bob: No!
(Mark:  Yeah, go for it, Bob!)
Bob:  No!
(Mark:  Please!)
Bob:  You know what? Okay...
Wade:  We already lead you into the only jumpscare we knew of, and I failed to get you on the second one so...
[wind howling]
Mark:  Man, I can't-- I can't hear you guys at all!  *laughs*
Bob:  Yeah, it's pretty fuckin' loud
Wade:  VERY ATMOSPHERIC
Mark:  OHH MY GOD!
Mark:  Oh there we go
(Bob: No no no no no no)
Mark:  Keep goin' forward, Bob.  You got this!
Bob:  Nope, nope, nope
(Mark: Push forward)
Wade:  Man, I love going slow through this cave that's collapsing around us!
Bob:  Yeah this seems like such a good place to be
Mark:  Yeah, you're almost there, Bob!
Bob:  Oh, I'm almost there, am I?
Mark:  Yeah, you are
(Wade: euuuhhh)
Bob:  I'm almost to the thing that you know is gonna get me?
Mark:  No, I meant the other side of the cave
Bob:  (unconvinced) Uh-huh, uh-huh, uh- huh, yeah, uh-huh
Bob:  Left or right?
Mark:  Uhhhhhhh
(Wade:  They both go over and connect here
Bob:  Okay..
Wade:  It's not really a fork
Mark:  Aaaand
(Bob:  What's that, what's that, what's THAT, what's that)
Bob:  Oh, it's a tree
(Mark: *laughs*)
Wade:  You know, we didn't explore over here to the right, but I do know the sniper rifle's to the left right here
Mark:  Yeah, Wade, you can have that one
Bob:  Yeah
Wade:  You sure?
Mark:  Yeah, I'll stick with the bear trap
(Bob:  Ah, shit!  Trees?? Dah!)
Bob:  (to Wade) Heeey, buddy, how's it going?
Wade:  Das Boot
(Bob:  Well, THAT seems good)
Mark:  Yep.  We're, yeah-- oh yeah, you found the mystery foot!
Wade:  I'm so bad with this gun, but okay
Wade:  Got it
Mark:  Yeah, so there's a lot of, uh...
Bob:  That's-- that's a HUGE leg
Mark:  Yeah!  I-- I know, right?
Bob:  It's like as big as your-- both of your legs put together
Mark:  Yeah, so you can imagine if the Rake killed THIS thing
Mark:  What'll it do to us??
(Bob: WE DON'T STAND A CHAAAANCE)
Mark:  (à la Troll 2)  AND THEN IT'S GONNA EAT ME
Mark:  OH MY GOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOD
(Bob:  *cracking up*)
Wade:  Oh, I noticed something
Wade:  Um, that's DEFINITELY the end of a leg and a foot
Wade:  I-- I can tell with binoculars
Mark:  Oh, thank you, man
Wade:  You're welcome
(Mark:  You're a lifesaver)
Mark:  I don't think there's anything around here
Wade:  Press, like, B or N on the keyboard and you can bring up binoculars
Mark:  B or N?
Wade:  Then, like, left click
Bob:  Holy shit
(Mark:  OOhh, wait...)
Mark:  N...
(Bob: Yeah, it's B)
Mark:  B?
Bob:  Wow, Wade, I can get a real close look at your completely white, blurred out face
Mark:  Oh, you have some night vision, too
Wade:  How do you turn that on?
(Bob:  Night vision??)
Mark:  Well, I mean, it's not really night vision, it's just you see a little bit better
Bob:  The flashlight works in the distance, as if it's being projected to the origin of the view for the uh...
Bob:  Binoculars
Mark:  Yeah, it's an intended feature, working as intended!
Mark:  I'm just looking around this area
Mark:  I don't think there's a house here... is there?
Wade: Yeah, might not be a house over here...
[loud crackling]
Bob: --like another NPC with a flashlight, just like, "Durdurdurrr"
Bob:  "Herpda" -- fuck, what?
Bob:  Whooa Jesus!
(Mark: What happened?)
Bob:  Lots of tree crackling noise, sounded like someone jumped out of a tree
Mark:  Yeah
[loud thump]
Mark:  Whoa...
(Bob:  Whoa, ho, whoa, whoa whoa, what??)
Mark:  *laughing* Oh, yeah, I forgot about that
Wade:  *laughs*
(Bob: Jesus!)
Mark:  That was the uh...
Mark:  That was the door
(Bob: God!)
Wade:  Just making sure you're nice and safe in there, Bob
Bob:  I switched that camera too, so I saw the door closing and then someone running away
Bob:  And I was just like, "OH NO THAT'S WHERE I AM"
Mark:  *laughs*
Bob:  *singing "Kumbuya" softly*
Mark:  I'm gonna go venture out...I'll be back
[thump]
(Mark: Maybe-- oh)
Bob:  Whoooa hey whoa, hey whoa, heeeeeeey
Wade: What?
Bob & Wade: *yelling*
Bob:  Oh no, it's here!
Mark:  What happened?
Wade:  I got bitch slapped!
Mark:  I'm comin' back!
Bob:  *laughing* The Rake came through and humped a- humped Wade and then ran away
Mark:  Oh, geez!
Wade:  OOWWW
Mark:  I leave for ONE goddamn second, and you guys--
Bob:  *cracking up*  I watched it happen on the camera, but I couldn't do anything to help him
Mark:  *laughing*
Mark:  I wanted to be SO braaaaaave
Bob:  Geez... I just switched to the camera and immediately all I hear is
Bob:  stomp stomp stomp stOMP sTOMP STOMP STOMP
Mark: *giggles*
Wade:  So, if you leave the camper, go to the right and just hug that right wall
Bob: --my god, what IS that?
Mark:  I gotta try to get back to the camper first...
Bob:  Is that... wait, is that--
Wade:  I'll wait to explore 'til you get here-- oh Bob's already inside
Mark: *tiny laugh*
(Bob: What IS that?)
Wade: I dunno
Rake:  *screeches*
(Mark: WHOOOA)
Bob:  aaHH SHIT FUCKING GODDAMN IT
Mark:  Ah, shit
(Bob: I mean... nothing)
Mark:  It had a-- it hit a lot of things!
[thump/crash]
Mark: Whoa
Wade:  *laughs* I think there was another trap- jumpscare in there
Bob:  Naaaah, nah-- I just... it's fine
Bob:  Hey, there's another sniper rifle up here
Mark: Ooh
Wade: I definitely had no idea that that would happen--
[Rake screeches]
Bob:  OH GOD fuckin' shit!
Wade: *laughs*
Bob: Jesus Christ!
Mark: Goddamn it, where are you guys??
Mark:  You're havin' all the fun!
(Wade: Go to the white wall!)
Mark:  I'm- I'm not even back to the camp!
Mark:  Ah, whooooaa!  That IS cool!
Wade:  Can we go down, inside the door?
Mark:  Eeehh, I doubt it
Mark:  Ooohh okay
Bob:  Aaaaahhhhh
Mark:  There's a blood up here
Wade: Is there anything in here Bob?
Mark:  Ooh!
Bob:  Not downstairs...
Mark: Oh, yeah, the sniper rifle. I'm takin' it!
Wade: All right
Mark:  Good thing I just died, so now I don't have to worry about losing my health... again
Wade:  Glad there's no jumpscares in here
Mark:  Yeah, that's- that's lovely
Bob:  Yeah, wow, what a relief!
Bob:  Man.... god
Wade:  That's a very normal sized arm to go with the giant foot we found
Bob:  I know!  *laughs*
Mark: *laughs*
Bob:  Maybe that guy just had real big legs
Mark:  Maybe...
Bob:  It's not a mystery, he just had big legs
Wade: *low voice* He didn't skip leg day
Mark:  *sarcastic laugh*
[bear trap snapping]
Mark: Oh, wow!
Wade: That sounds...look at the Rake's health!  Is that just from him running into traps?
Mark:  Oh, yeah yeah
Bob:  What an idiot
Bob:  What an asshole
Mark:  I mean eventually he'll just kill himself.  You wanna go back to camp and just, like, kill him?
Bob:  Yeah, let's just let him kill himself, fuck yeah
Wade:  Yeah, now that Bob got all the jumpscares, I'm feeling pretty- pretty content with myself
[creepy wind]
(Mark: Wuh-oh- why? noises?)
Wade:  I don't know, those weren't here when we came here the first time
Mark:  Those are... that's NEW noises
Wade:  Yeah, I've not heard that one before
Mark: That's weird!
(Mark: It's like some bree- eeuuh)
[howling]
Mark:  Whoa
Bob: Oh god... Wade I'm lost
Bob: Wade, wait for me!
[odd growling]
Wade:  Bob I- I'm gonna go up the hill...
Mark:  I'm lookin' over there...
(Bob: 'Kay bye)
Bob:  Well, here I'll watch the camera so I can see when you die
Wade:  Die??
Mark:  I mean- I'm lookin' at ya!
I see ya up that hill
Bob:  Hey, Wade
Wade:  There's a suspicious dead body on all of our bear traps
Bob & Mark: *laughing*
Mark:  What?? Nooooo way
Bob:  Oh, no Wade Wade Wade Wade Wade!
Bob: Wade Wade Wade!
Mark:  Wade?
Wade: *pained groan*
Bob: Mark he's coming towards camp!
Bob:  Mark, camp! Mark- coming down the hill
Mark:  Oh, oh, oh, okay all right- all right
[footsteps]
Mark:  Aaaahhh, he's right right behind me- WHOA!!
[gun firing]
Mark: Whoa!
Bob:  I got him!
Mark:  Oh, he's stuck, he's stuck!  He's stuck in a loop!
Bob:  Oh, he's stuck, shoot the shit out of him!
Wade:  He's after whoever's on the roof, that's why he's broken
Mark:  Yeeeeaaah, he's after me!
Bob:  *cracking up* Oh my god!
Bob:  *losing it*
Mark:  YEEEEAAAH oh shootin' gallery now!
Mark:  Lil' bitch!
Bob:  How close do you think we can get, Wade?
Mark:  Don't- don't get too close
Mark:  I wanna kill him... oh wow
Bob & Mark: *cracking up*
Bob:  *losing it*
Mark:  Ooooohh wow
Bob:  You know what?  Wade, Wade, not like this
Bob:  Not like this
Mark:  *laughs* Not like this!
Mark:  Oh, almost!  Little more!
Bob:  I'm almost out of bullets
Mark:  I've got a few more
Bob:  Wade, you're gonna have to use your gun
Bob:  Oh no- oh I thought he was going to escape
Mark:  He- he's movin' so fast!  I can't see his moves!
Bob:  Does anyone have any traps?  You think we should put a trap down right by his feet-
Mark: Hang on, I think I got one more- one more shot in me
Wade: Don't miss
Mark:  All right, bye
Mark:  Wait-
Bob:  You MISSED
Mark: Sh- it's- goddamn it!
Bob:  Mark!
Mark:  YEEEEEAAHHH
Bob:  Yeeaah!
Mark:  Markimoo win!
Wade: *low voice* One shot, one kill
Bob:  Muyskerm win!
Mark: *laughing* Yeeeahh!
Mark:  Aaawww
Bob:  All right!
Wade:  There's the end!
Mark:  *laughing* The end??
Mark:  WOOOOOOO!!!!
Bob:  *laughing*
Mark:  Yaaaaaay!
Wade:  Oohh my goodness
Mark:  What a game
Bob:  Hoooooooly shitballs
Bob:  It was fun, but it wasn't fun because the GAME was good
Mark:  Yeeeeeah, that's the thing, like it's fun because of what you make of it
Bob:  *laughing*  It was fun because it was ridiculous
Wade:  The open world horror aspects really cool, but then...
Wade:  The jumpscares are good that happen, but other than that
Bob:  It's just needs to be, like a whole game.  I mean it's in alpha right, so...
Mark:  Yeah, eventually, it'll...
Wade: Yeah, eventually... nine months ago they quit working on it...
Bob:  *laughs*
Mark:  *inhales deeply*  Mmmmmm
Bob:  Oh my gosh
Mark:  Oh, well...
Wade:  But imagine what this game could've been had it left...
Wade:  Alpha 0.0.1
Mark:  That's a good way to look at things, so we'll end on that note!
Mark:  Thanks, guys, so much for watching!
Mark:  Check out Bob and Wade's channels in the description below for more cool stuff that we've done
Mark:  And thank you everybody for watching
Mark:  And as always, we'll see YOU... in the next video
Mark:  BUH-BYE!
*Outro plays*